so what do you get when you cross two of
the most attractive and well-paid actors
in the movie industry the tourists
alright so going into this movie I knew
nothing about the tourists which might
be a good thing because if I saw the
trailer I'd just be going seeing that
before seeing that before that's been
done before
for two solid minutes granted it
probably beats doing it for two solid
hours which is what I just did so the
gist of the movie is Angelina Jolie's
this spy type chick who's connected with
this unseen master thief type guy who's
wanted by the mob and a zillion agencies
spread across 14 different countries
including Scotland Yard and so Angelina
Jolie ropes in Johnny Depp's character
who's this tourist go figure and now
everyone thinks that he is actually the
thief guy okay now look good I know
you're waiting for me to say it so I
will just say it Johnny Depp made this
movie I thought he was great because he
was remarkably average it goes to show
you that in a world where Johnny Depp
isn't like Johnny Depp he's not Jack
Sparrow he is and he can be just an
average guy personally I think he stole
the show well yeah of course him in the
plethora of Angelina Jolie ass shots
those were great - I love them both
equally but for different reasons
remember when your parents used to tell
you that yeah I'm not gonna lie it was
probably just as much then -
but this movies kind of intriguing for
the first half but it is so slow I
understand sometimes movies have to do
that for character development but there
were no characters developed Johnny
Depp's dialogue and Angelina's a shot
scary the movie for the first half then
the movie picks up - his steady crawl
which in retrospect seems like lightning
but it still a crawl I mean it's a
spiced type movie that's been done
literally a billion times before what
happened to the days when spy movies
would be like gotcha and quite frankly
the movies really really predictable you
know how it's gonna end within the first
seven minutes so the acting is good the
dialogue is actually really good but
that's like having the right amount of
sugar and spice and a bowl of month-old
room-temperature broccoli soup so
because of Johnny Depp's acting and
Angelina just being so sexy I would say
the movies alright but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus seven seconds
Depp doesn't care that was like I'm in
Pirates for it doesn't matter in
Angelina's like everyone's
still wants to be in me so it doesn't
matter I think they'll be okay but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more